- Okay, so I mean, Quaid
might be your last name,
but you also go by another
name, what is that?
I hear you have a nickname.
- Oh yes, my friends refer
to me as Pool Noodle.
(laughing)
- No!
- You've seen them in pools.
- Yeah.
- They're just those like,
giant macaroni-looking
things that you float on.
- (laughs) How tall are you?
- It's just kind of the shape of my body
and the fact that I, you know,
I'm lanky and I'm noodle-y.
And these are friends that have known me
since middle school, in which I was
way more uncoordinated.
(laughing)
And it just seemed like I
had no bones, but I feel
like I should feel lucky
that my nickname is Pool
Noodle and not Inner Tube.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
you just took my joke.
I was like, I had another
one, mine was Inner Tube.
No, literally, I would
love if people called me
a pool noodle.
- Pool noodle!
- (laughs) I'd be like,
"I am feeling thin today."
No, that's awesome.
So this summer though, your
girlfriend shared this photo.
So, whose idea was this?
- Oh!
(laughing)
- [Kelly] 'Cause it's awesome.
- It's Liz's, that was Liz's.
She has this talent for kind
of finding really random,
insane, amazing experiences in new cities.
This is in Toronto.
I had no idea I was going
and basically, she was like,
"Come with me, we're
gonna do something fun."
I'm like, "All right."
And we wound up going
to the YMCA in Toronto
and there were all these
people with mermaid tails.
It was a mermaid class.
This is a thing you can do.
It's an entire culture, apparently.
They refer to themselves as merfolk.
(laughing)
They have Mercons.
And I took the class and you
know, I put on a monofin.
I know all the terminology now.
(laughing)
- You're a merman, okay.
This is so funny.
- Oh my God.
- My four year old boy
is literally obsessed.
He wants to be a merman.
- Aw!
- He's obsessed, 'cause
I think they were on,
Aquaman was on here?
- Oh, yeah.
- And so from that moment,
he's all into like, yeah.
- That actually sounds
up my alley, weirdly.
I'd be into the mermaid
thing, I think that's so cool.
- And you're the greatest boyfriend ever.
You just showed up at something.
You had no idea and you were like,
"I guess I'll be a merman,"
like what boyfriend does that?
- Also, I don't want to brag,
but I'm kind of great at being a mermaid.
(laughing)
I took to it really quickly.
Like, I'm to the point where,
when we shot season two of "The Boys,"
the next year, we did it
again at a different YMCA.
And that was, right after the class,
it was my first time getting
recognized for the show.
- Oh!
- Oh my gosh, I love you!
- So there was a guy that
came up and he was like,
"Oh, I saw you um, doing your thing,
but I didn't want to interrupt,
but I love the show."
So I'm like, "Okay, of course, yeah.
The first time I get
recognized for the show,
I'm wearing a skirt, a mermaid skirt."
- A tail, that's amazing.
(laughing)
I love you so much,
that you're down for stuff like that.